それでまあ 今日のテーマに入ります
ブッダが説かれる世界勝利者への道
生活はあり合わせで 仏道に入る人に
いわゆる出家者に お釈迦様が初めからもう人生に挑戦することを教えるんです
決まってるパターンで生きることじゃなくて
挑戦させるんです 衣は拾った布切れを縫い合わせて使うのが理想的であると
これは何とかの店で 何とかの人が作った衣でなければ
あまり履き心地が良く
これは良くないとかね
これは仏教では禁止なんです
拾ったもので縫い合わせて使ってくださいと
それがうまくどれぐらいうまく上手に気持ちよく使うのかって
その人の挑戦なんです
食べ物は人が鉢の中に入れたもので十分ですと
それ以外何も考えるなよと
入ったものは食べてみなさい
それはどうかな 自分の味
味の味覚とどう闘うのか
それは自分の挑戦 自分の体調とどうか
それはもう知ったものじゃない
自分でそれは何とかしなさいと
住む家は木の下で十分ですと
薬は牛の尿さえあれば間に合いますと
他人にあれが欲しい これが欲しいと頼んではならないんですね
出家したら このような質素な生き方は理性的であると説かれると
我々の頭の頑固さがなくなるんです
理性的的な生き方はこれだと
この最小限を理性にしてみると
頭が動かないと 頭の頑固さがなくなるんですよ
例えば草履を履かないで裸足で生活してみると
もうもう私たちみたいにバカみたいにずっと周りも環境も下を見ないで歩くってしません
私は国へ帰ったら大体もう履かないんですけど
お寺の庭とかあちこち行ったりはしますよ
トゲがあるわ 石があるわ
もうもう何か だからずっとチェックしながら
で 頭が動くんですよ こちらに足を踏んじゃうと
このウジキソウのトゲでやられますから
はい こちらにということで
こちらは泥があるんだから
こちらに足を入れと この石がやばいんだだからもうちょい先の方に足を踏むそうと
ただ裸足になっただけで
ずっと頭が回転してますよ
それにブーツとか履いてみてください
バカみたくどこでも行くんだから
だから能力要らなくなっちゃうんです
だって ハイキングするためにはあるし
ジョギングのブーツあるし
山を登る時のその山登りのまた作ってあるし
あれで経験済みますか？バカになるかどちらかわからないんです
まあ今も私はそのすごい歩きにくい険しいところだったら
やっぱり裸足で行きたいんです
その方が体も動くし 頭も動くし
より安全で行けます 最低限で命をつなぐ方法を考える人間になる
怠けがなくなる 一番大きなポイント
怠けがなくなるんです
ものの多面性を発見するんです
例えば木の下で寝ると
木のこの根がね 枕として十分十分いいんじゃないかとかね
ここら辺は背もたれにいいんじゃないかとかね
発見するでしょうね だから
この多面性を発見することは智慧の始まりで
邪見の終わりなんですよ
だからもうブッダは別に苦行を語ったわけじゃないんです
この邪見を破って 怠けを破って
ものの多面性を発見して
悟りに達するための道を説いてるんです
あの律宗で衣のやり方を書いてますよ
衣が穴が開いたりすると着てはいけないんです
社会として情けないんだと
だらしないんだと 穴は縫って綺麗に
かっこよく見える 作ることできれば OK ですけど
どうせ古着だから まあ修理したってもうまくいかない時期が来るんです
その時は衣を捨ててはいけないんです
大きいんだから それはちょっと折って敷いて
その上に寝たり もっと小さく折ってみると
座布団代わりになったり
枕の代わりになったりするんです
そういう風に使いなさい
それでもこれまた古くなるでしょうね
そうすると それをまた畳んでおいて
この足 マットにマット代わりに使う
足を洗いますからね 昔は中に入ると前入る前に足を洗ったら足を拭いたりするために
タオル代わりに使う 今はタオルなければダメでしょうね
で 昔はまあ衣古い衣でやったりする
はい それでもボロボロになったら
壁 自分住んでる部屋の壁なんか作ったりすれば
あの粘土と一緒に混ぜて壁に塗っておくと
そうすると土が硬くなるんです
割れ 割れたりしないんですね
乾くと つなぎつないでくれます
そういう風にもうきめ細かく書くんですよ
律宗を読んでみると いかにこのあり合わせで生活することを教えているか
すごい例があるんですよ
病気になったらどうしようかとかね
ですから心は安らぎに感じるんです
あの道具 この道具だと道具に依存すると
必要なものは限りなく出てきますからね
いくらあっても足らないという精神異常状態になります
心に激しい欲 渇愛 悩み
不満が生じるんです あり合わせで生活する出家は
まずこの精神異常から解放されるのです
私の部屋も同じです 私にいる場所がないんです
いっぱい物がいっぱいありまして
そんな精神異常にはなりませんよ
お釈迦様がおっしゃった通りに生活すると穏やかにいられます
あるもので間に合っちゃえばいいんです
やっぱりこれがなければ
あれがなければになってくると
物は増えて増えていくだけ
どんどん怒りやら憎しみやら
もういっぱい出てくるんです
頭が柔軟になるので明るいんです
既成概念と執着と苦というテーマに入ります
怠けの衝動で生きている生命は心を解放したくありません
だから怠けで じゃあやっぱりこの道具使いましょう
これ何かなければとかね
だから心を自由にしたくないんです
新しいものを考えたくないんです
既成概念 習慣 習慣 規則
信仰 決まりなどがあれば
その路線の上に滑らせていただきたいと思っているのです
普通みんなそうですよ
社会で決まっている路線に
滑らせていただきたいと
悪いこと自分で滑ってみようという気持ちもないんです
滑ることが他人が滑らせなくちゃいけないんですよ
どれぐらいな負けかというと
あ これ面白い 滑ってみようかね
それもないんです 暗黒の中で唯我独尊で生きてる生命の中で
稀な人は光を求めるんです
だから世界はもう暗黒の中で唯我独尊気分で生きています
その中で稀な人ですよ
光を探すのは 光を求めるものは社会の水害をでしたっけ？迫害を気にせず
自己改革路線を歩んでみるんです
社会はもう決まってる道で歩めと言ってますが
気にしないで この解放の世界で頑張ってみようとするんです
その稀な人々の中でも
能力がある人々は 真理を発見したブッダに出会うんです
社会システムから出て頑張る人はいくらでもいますけど
やっぱり頭の悪い無知な人々はあんまりブッダには合わないんですね
だから このその稀な人々の中で
また稀な人々はブッダに出会うんです
出家するんです 出家がまずタラレバネバの敗北者の精神状態を乗り越えなくてはならないんです
一旦出家した途端 このタラレバネバはダメ
それはもうこれが禁止になってしまうんです
他人に文句を言ったり
指をさしたりしないで
今ここであるもので真理を発見するんです
いい先生に出会わ出会わないんだとかね
自分が住んでいる場所はあまり良くない
だから文句ばっかりで
これやらない人々なんですよ
だから これ 頭がすごい自由になれば
どこでも真理があるんです
それから最小限と甘美という言葉で考えてみましょう
特に人は体調が良くなったら
健康食品を食べて健康な肉体を作ってから
ヨーガを行って肉体の調整をしてから
子供が独立してから 会社を退職してから
年を取って会社の義務を果たせなくなってから
西洋人の間で人気があるならば
皆行っているならば 道場は五つ星のホテル並みにできているならば
自分の考えを認めてくれるならば
自分を高く評価してくれるなら
金になるならば 超能力で社会人に自慢できるならば
病気で末期状態であるならば
認知症になっているならば
心を育てることに挑戦する計画
です 一つも私は言い過ぎじゃないんです
世界にある事実なんです
だからみんなたらればばっかりで
大宇宙が破滅するまで修行のチャンスは得られないでしょう
それだったら 私は白昼白獣の王者です
誰か私を捕まって檻に入れて飼ってくれという願い
期待 希望で生きているんですよ
人間の生き方ってそんな生き方
私は偉いんだよと しかし誰か飼ってくれと
しかし ここだけの話ですけど
買ってくれと期待するのは捨て犬
捨て猫などです 最初  これ違う
これ最初からもう嫌われて用なしの存在です
だから あれこれやと条件を言うね
ちょっと年取ってから退職してから考えますとか
まあこれだったらまあもう宇宙が破壊するまでもできないですよ
社会に捨てられると修行に励む人の例ですよ
だからだいたい社会に捨てられると
まあじゃあ仏教でも修行でもやってみようかなと
何考えてるのか私にわかりませんだけど
私にはすごい迷惑ですけど
最小限は社会の怠けに支配されている生き方に対する挑戦でもあります
ですから お釈迦様のこの最小限論理は
この社会に このくだらない社会に対してすごい挑戦なんです
心を活性化することになりますね
私は修行しているのだと社会に見せて認めてもらう目的は
仏教では全然ないんです
社会は相手にもしていないんです
しかし 現代時代では誰かに認めてほしいんで
だから社会に人気あるかないか
それはチェックポイントなんですよ
いろんな宗教組織の中で
タレントさんが信仰してくれるかないかとかね
宗教のパワーで人気になるんじゃなくて
タレントさんの人気で自分を売ってしまうという
情けないのはいいところなんです
だから信じる必要は全くないんです
あの まあ一応それが思い出したんで忘れます
社会で評価されている断食
滝行 苦行などを真似することは
仏弟子は行いません そこで時々宗教の世界でも修行するんですよ
よくよく見ると その修行が社会が評価しているんです
社会が評価しているんだからやるんです
社会様に認められて反抗してくれるんだだから汝はもうもう覚醒しましたと
そこら辺のおじいさん
おばあさんに 若者に 何もうちゅうまいところです
釈尊に説かれた最小限の原理に従う
だからブッダの弟子たちは社会で修行として何を解こうか
全く無視 ブッダに説かれた最小原理で生きているんです
最小限と精神的強さ あれは完備していなければというね
完備するということは
私 リストを書いたんだからね
そういうものを全部準備完了だったら修行するんだっていうのは話にならないということで
しかし 最小限と出てくるのは精神的強さなんですね
目的地まで車で行くか歩くのか
車で行く人は道具のお世話になりますね
これは例でわかりやすいと思います
歩く人は自分の体を期待するんですよ
車で行く人は道具に依存する
歩く人は自分の体に期待する
肉体も精神も強くなるでしょ
その場合は目的地まで目的地まで歩きましょうという人が
もう精神的 肉体的にも強いんです
やっぱり車タクシー拾いましょうというと
道具に頼るんですね あれもこれも必要だと思う人は
自分自身を発展させようとしないんです
だから あれも必要 これも必要と
あれやればこれやればという人は
決して自己開発 自分を発展しようという気持ちはないんです
この上の例えで大体わかります
だからといって長い距離を別に歩きなさいと言っているわけじゃないんです
一応この例えでわかるんです
ポイントだけ 今あるもので間に合うようにする人は
自分を発展させているんです
だから この間に合うようにする人は自分自身を発展しているんです
だから最小限イコール精神の的な強さなんです
物に道具に依存する人は自分に合わせて外の環境を変えるんです
だから自分の都合によって世界環境を変えるんですよ
怠け者が 自分は変わらないんですね
最小限の人は環境を最小限で変えるが
実際は自分を変えるんです
それで道具を作る我々は何をやっているか
自分が怠けのまんまで
その代わりに世界を破壊するんです
物に頼らない人は環境は破壊しないんです
その代わりに自分を開発して持っていくんです
環境破壊の道は世間の道
環境破壊です 自己開発の道は仏道です
正反対です えーと 休憩にしますかね
じゃあこのセクションから休憩で 10 分ぐらい
はい